all right Tatiana yes Tatiana where you
from originally where didd you grow up I
grew up in San Fernando Valley right in
the city of Bima and North Hollywood H
tell me about your family you had Mom
and Dad uh I do have a mom and dad I was
raised by my grandmother and my aunt
mostly which is my mother's youngest
sister those are the those are my
parents right there really what happened
to your mom and dad my mom and dad they
separated and when my father my
stepfather got custody of me and my
brothers he had he had given me the
opportunity to ask if I wanted to go
live with him or did I want to stay with
my mom my grandmother and my aunt at
that time and obviously I used to love
going to my grandmother and my aunt's
house every weekend no matter what and I
decided to choose them and stay with
them so my brothers went with my father
and I stayed behind with my grandmother
and my aunt how old were you I was at I
was exactly 10 years old when they had
asked me that mhm and were there signs
that you
were different than your brothers a
little different yeah I always thought
it was just another typical gay boy
thing but I didn't I didn't discover
this until like later on in my years of
my life when how old are you now I am 32
32 and you you kind
of became trans at what age at the age
of
exactly you feel like you were born this
way or you feel like something happened
to you when you were young it was
something I was born with I just didn't
realize it until the following year I
didn't discover the reason why I wanted
to be a woman and the reason why it was
cuz my I was raised by women only and
very very a lot of very strong
women I just you know didn't real I
didn't realize it until the last strong
woman in my family passed passed away
this year a couple months ago and the
women that raised you accepted that your
your your I never gave them the chance
to they died before they could get the
chance to even give me the opportunity
to show them I was too scared I didn't
know how they could accept
it they were very very strong Christian
women so in Christianity it's like a
little harder for me
to explain to him and make him
understand if it was a God or not
but I wouldn't know I never gave him the
chance you're Hispanic yes so that makes
it even harder I think yeah that does
make it a little harder the culture
doesn't yeah accept this as much as
maybe
others yeah most most other cultures
especially in Latino cultures we mothers
are all about you know like their boys
are the Macho ones and they're all like
you know the ones that take care of the
family but they didn't never real
realized that there was no men in our
family to take care of them so what
machoness do we have to
perpetrate if they were the ones that
were the ma ones they were the ones
taking care of the family currently
you're living in the streets yes I am
currently living on the streets what
part of town um in the part of um Studio
City and North Hollywood which is on
violin and like um Aqua Vista MH around
that area you're staying under a bridge
yes I am and you
you've been doing this for how many
years about approximately five years
already tell me about that
lifestyle the lifestyle is hard it's
very hard to adjust especially in the
beginning of it but it is a little bit I
will I won't lie it is relieving and it
is it's it feels
free like you're able to do anything you
want any time you want no matter what
rules are around there's no rules around
but honestly it is
exhausting it's sometimes to live by the
day by day bread by Bread it's very
exhausting like not to expect to either
you're going to eat tomorrow you're not
going to eat tomorrow choose to eat
tomorrow or choose L to eat tomorrow how
do you survive how do you generate money
um thank God for there's there's a lot
of
government um programs out there that
help us with any type of um income like
gr and food STS and then I go to the
food banks of the churches around town
and they'll give out food and stuff too
A lot of the trans women that I've
interviewed
um they'll make money oh the the that
way no you don't do that never I I've
I've been told a lot by my my my sisters
that they do that I I don't think I ever
ever want to ever do that to myself even
as a boy I never did it I would never do
it because it's like if I want to be a
woman I want to be respected as a woman
not as a as a
sex image object object to them and my
my my mother and my grandmother never
showed themselves that way to my father
and my grandfather I mean that's only
the reason they got married so to me I
would never ever do that I'm it never
crosses my mind yeah occasionally I
won't lie yes I take that back it has
crossed my mind times cuz it sees how
easily it could be
done but yet again I would not want to
disrespect myself that
way and emotionally do
you what do you go through living this
life emotionally I go through a lot a
lot of stress and a lot of depression I
recently just gave up my baby girl right
now my dog so it's it's very very hard
to cope with that because you you really
want to have a companion like a dog with
you because it's like they understand
and they listen to you even though they
can't talk back they they they're good
listeners and um but then yet again they
don't deserve a life like the way we
have it right now especially for them
and if we love our companions we'll
we'll give them whatever the best we can
and honestly giving her up for adoption
was the best I could
do do you have friends I have a ke I
have a lot of friends I won't say
they're friends that I
could keep forever I mean friends come
and go just people on the streets yeah
people on the streets we never know when
one person disappears on us and either
dies from a drug overdose or they go to
prison that's the only reason why I say
that yeah I have friends that come and
go
but I do have my
family my street family out here
um we're weak but we're strong in heart
but that's all pretty much yeah are
drugs a part of your life yes drugs are
a part of my life I won't lie about that
they are very very big part of my life
and it sucks sometimes when they are
controlling my life is that crystal meth
yes it is Crystal
math such a popular drug right now I
know it's I think the whole world is
starting to really start to do it now
more than just the people on the streets
which just
crazy do you have goals for yourself
you'd like to I have goals for myself um
one goal is to get off the
streets
to maybe get a job again I know I could
get a job instantly if I if I put myself
out there again I went to school and
everything so I I have the knowledge and
and the certificates and the degrees to
get to any type of job that I want is it
harder being trans trying to get a I've
never tried it as a trans that's the
thing I I was always scared of the I
already
am parano I already get paranoid and
anxiety from the Judgment that people
give me on the streets just by walking
by somebody and having the eyes being
stared at
me it it might be much more harder for
me to cope with it when it work
like how would my co-workers feel with
it how would the emplo how would the
customers feel about it because I always
worked at a company that involved
customer care and like one-onone
interaction with a customer like a
bank so I don't know if the bank will
ever see that type of image like an
image for them you get
me is this a lonely lifestyle for you it
is because honestly then then that's
when I started Living the world as a boy
and the day and the and the night as as
a girl and that's when it started to
mess with my mind a
lot are you a woman all day now yes
that's the
only up good thing about me being on the
streets now is that I get to live the
life that I want to live fully I don't
have to go home to my parents house and
hide this image because I don't know how
they're going to take this
image and
honestly my parents I already told
everybody at my grandmother's funeral
this image and everybody seemed to take
it where they're like accepting
more and it was only my grandmother's
opinion that I was so scared of taking
it bad CU if she would have told me I
don't accept it you need to be a boy I
will do it for her even though I would
be miserable but I will do it for her
are you happier now I am super happy
that I'm who I am but it just just sucks
that I don't have the one person I wish
I could share it with do you feel
misunderstood yes a lot do you get any
rough things that happen to you being
transed on the street oh yeah I've been
sexually and physically abused a
lot thinking that in my mind now I put
my mind as a woman that if a man beats
the the crap out of me that it's like I
can't defend myself and it sucks because
like
if I defend myself then the man
remembers that I also have in between my
legs something that they have as well
and then they take it to the point where
it's no longer a woman being beaten up
it's a man now in their mind because and
so and we are put so much down that we
need to become a woman and so a woman is
weak or to a man's fight and it it sucks
because it gets to my mind too that I
had to show my weakness and even though
I I know I'm stronger I can't cuz then I
I recognize myself that's not as the
woman that I portray all the time you
feel like Society is starting to accept
trans people more oh yes I mean I think
our community is accepting it at all I
see I don't know how many trans girls
that I've never met ever on the streets
even trans women um trans men um the
ones that go from female to male there's
one that works at the 7-Eleven down the
street for me
and it's always we always say hi to each
other and it's it's weird how we tell
each other we were born in different we
were born in the brong sex but it's
crazy how like how we wish we could
trade our spots
together and um yeah I see a lot more of
the trans Community out there in the
community in in working communities that
I've never thought ever in my life I
thought that I seen a trans ever until I
became one I started seeing who was an
actual Trans in the world
it was hard I could never had told I
would never had
noticed what is your greatest strength
what's your favorite quality about
yourself I am very very creativity C
creative creative yeah so when it comes
to like a certain situation I can always
come up with the
best um
results of the best strategy to come up
with the best result at the end even
though everybody never wants to listen
to me and no one ever does it I somehow
get my my my my push in there somehow in
their their their part of the world
where they don't even notice that I
still did it even though they did they
they think they did
it I guess it's a manipulative way in a
good form like
if I'm I know that I'm a good
manipulator but I mean I do it in a way
where it's not going to harm the other
person not myself either
what is your dream situation to be in in
five
years I want to be a
mom I think
so I think if it's possible for me to
have a kid I probably would want to have
a kid because I guess it's like having
Street kids which I do and having my
pets as a mom by myself and not even
having a boyfriend or or a husband at
the time of having the these people in
my life I think I could just be a mom by
myself and I don't know maybe 5 years
from now hopefully I'll have everything
stable and steady and maybe I want to
adopt one instead of having one mhm do
you think that would be confusing for
the young boy or young girl no because I
I will again I will always put it out
there in the beginning of my child's
life that no matter what I'm always this
mom never never mistaken that just
because you see something that is
similar to us I'm always going to be
your mom just like that my mom was my
father my grandmother was my father my
aunt was my father they were all my
father and my mother no matter what like
even though they like my mom she's a
lesbian she's she's what petrays a
masculine lesbian and
um I see her as my mother still I don't
see her as my father even though she
looks like a boy dresses like a boy but
she doesn't want to be a boy but to me
that's still my mother no matter what
and that's who I see right there what
kind of jobs have you had I've been a I
was a manager and a supervisor
throughout every job that I had um I
started off at
CVS I worked for them for like about 7
years um from the age of 16 to the age
of 23 and then I went from there to
another company worked there for 4 years
as a store manager and then I went to
another company a loan office where I
started working with finance and a bank
and everything that was the last job I
ever had was a pretty much how many
years ago was that that was about that
was in 2021 so a couple years ago mhm
what's keeping you from working now is
it the drug problem yeah it will
probably be the drug problem all your
other homeless friends are probably in
the same same boat with drugs probably
yeah I don't ever ever do I say I'm ever
starving or am I drain of no no um of of
no food or anything I could always
somehow come up with it and provide for
myself at any time especially not just
for myself but for everybody in the
community whereever whoever was there
with me that day if I I'm not just going
to go in the store and be like oh what
am I hungry for but no I call everybody
be like what do you guys want I want
something I'll get you there something
right
here are there places you can go Miss
that will feed yeah there are a lot of
the churches in our community right
there in our Hollywood in Studio City
they do a lot of the the the the lunches
and the the breakfast in the morning
know L people do a lot of night things
around our neighborhood but I mean
that's when you go to like downtown Lane
they do night ones out there but it's a
little too far by then we already had
eaten enough for us to have food and
St but I always like to cook at my spot
anyways mhm what would you say is your
biggest fear now
then one day I'll meet the wrong person
that doesn't accept this type of
lifestyle and I won't end up coming back
from it that's one of my biggest
fears you think it's dangerous for
you yeah I live day by day in a
dangerous World cuz one day one guy
might not think this through and might
be confused and might take it upon
himself to either hurt me very very
bad and I don't come back from it and I
didn't get to finish the rest of my life
the way I wanted to all because of a
little situation like that that's what
I'm afraid of every
day have you been in love before yes I
have three about two times in my
life and what happened
there uh my first love was my first
boyfriend in high school
seven years of going through that misery
was a lot for
me um the second one was the guy
actually did this
for um I actually dressed up for a guy
cuz I met him online I won't lie and he
was only into trans or crossdressers or
the feminine boy and I was nothing like
that so when I met him I fell in love
with his intelligence his his his
Charisma and who he was and that's who I
wanted to be I was like that's who I
should have married that's who I should
have been with but obviously he didn't
he's not going to see me in any form
other way but a friend
so I had a trans friend at the time and
I asked her I need you to turn me into
one of you as quick as possible as less
surgery or any type of form just do what
you got to do and so she did she she she
transformed me into someone that I was
like who the hell is this in the mirror
but I when I saw it she saw my face and
she's like you like it huh I'm like I do
I don't
why it was just weird and just it was it
was exciting like I liked it like I
don't know dressing up like that was for
the first time was very very
intense and then now I just do it now
for myself every day I don't do this for
no one else but myself and I don't care
what people say about me or what people
think about
me
um it's not them who I'm trying to
impress if I go out looking like the way
I want to go out looking like and I feel
confident about it then I'm
good but there I know there are still
the judgments out there and there's
always going to be judgment out there
but who are they they're not my Creator
they they're not the ones that made me
who I am and they're not the ones that
are going to make me who I am in the
future have you heard surgeries no oh
but not not for the transcendal part um
that's what I mean huh yeah attempts to
be more feminine uh no no no um no
hormones not yet I have gotten on the
schedule already to get to that part but
I have to go through therapy again and
and figure out if this is a true like a
a real for sure thing because once you
start you don't want to stop and if if
you stop and then you start like it's
just going to the hormone balance in
your body system is going to start
messing with your mind and it's just not
it's not a right thing to do to your
head at all so you had I think I should
go back to therapy and go through that
process again make sure that this is the
right decision that I'm
making because honestly like as a girl I
ended up on the streets I lost a lot of
family members lifetime because I wasn't
really there as a boy I was always there
with my family I was there
24/7 I was all about my family and just
them but as a girl I'm all about about
myself and me and I feel as a girl I'm
selfish or
selfless but it sucks because it's like
the one thing that I love the most was
being a family person I love being there
for my
family but I can't be there for my
family and then be miserable in the
inside of
it I was like like to be happy at least
for once in a while and I chose to be
happy for once in a while and
now I don't see what's so happy about
this but I am happy I don't know why
it's hard to explain to why I'm happy
even though I'm in my situation where
I'm on the streets no job no money
nothing you're free but I'm free I'm
free to be who I am and that's what
makes me happy
mhm T I know what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your
life
huh don't
take life for granted I guess it's like
don't just because you are trying to
make the world Happy does not make you
happy you need to make yourself happy
the most and that's my one thing is
about everybody being happy not being
misle no negativity nothing like that
and maybe this world wouldn't be the way
it is if everybody just smiled and be
happy and actually be themselves
all right Tatiana thank you so much for
sharing your story no problem thank you
wish you lots of luck out there thank
you